you
member
haha
the silicon must get neta will not apply
and your money but lying i show how good
are they to get in Italian Supercup
another block yoga club okay Thomas
visits area Kodomo a bully up their work
at NASA
hi everybody just the two words of
welcome I mean I've I think I'm a lucky
person like I have a lot of good luck
and and the best sign of that is that if
every now and then you meet somebody
that's just astonishing and makes
everything you've been doing yourself
seem irrelevant and then significant and
your speaker tonight is one of those
people and it's sort of great when the
person that you meet that makes
everything you do seem stupid as an
architect because it means at least you
didn't make a stupid decision about
which field to be in but so rare it is
to find an architect that has been able
to take what it is that that I mean
Arctic's all have two things in common
one is stupidity because they are in a
discipline whose relationship to culture
is always precarious so they always have
to argue for architecture the dentist
doesn't have to argue for teeth for
example and and the second great thing
that I click share is they're in love
they're absolutely in love with
buildings and that the second one is the
explanation of the first one because
they're in love they go crazy and they
don't think about getting an important
job like being a plumber or a lawyer or
something like that so to meet an
architect that transforms their love of
buildings into love and a deeper sense
this is an amazing thing and the end
that it happens through
preservation is super super interesting
i think we are very used to the idea
that preservation teaches the other
disciplines of the built environment to
take care I mean preservation is always
a kind of a warning but here it's at
some completely different scale this is
an architect trained at the great school
at AUB and american university of beirut
michigan edinboro which is itself
already an amazing combination if you
think about you know living on the
states and Scotland brought up in the
astonishingly beautiful city of a man
that's a city in which the oldest Street
in archaeological evidence was was found
Neolithic Street which makes Jericho
seem like a late comer so literally a
city sitting not only at the great
intersection of everything but literally
in a certain sense to the birthplace of
our concept of what our city is but then
somebody who falls in love on as if I
understand right as a tourist to the
West Bank falls in love with somebody in
Ramallah so love again and so lives in
Ramallah and moves there and then writes
this sort of shocking book and there are
big issues facing our world like peace
poverty water equity social justice but
the biggest of all is surely
mother-in-laws I mean because this is
this seems to be the least likely to be
solved and this is an astonishingly
elegant book in 19 different languages
describing what it means to be as it
were forced to live with one's mother in
law during a 42-day curfew so as it were
to develop also in an intimate
relationship with the man who imprisoned
you with your mother-in-law in this way
in this case Chiron produces this
amazing books your honor my
mother-in-law which which is literally i
think in something like 19 or something
languages but should but it's again a
book full of humor and tenderness and
and and and it keeps going and going i
mean if i say anything more you you know
it will be a problem but they have to
say something but important part of the
peace delegation in washington but
probably even more important to my naive
mind to be very very active in
initiatives between palestine
there's a really woman and it seems to
me again this the the different kind of
care for for the for the situation also
a member of government director-general
of the ministry of culture but but for
us tonight founder and director of the
ReWalk center for architectural
conservation that you saw the film which
is starting in nineteen ninety one
devoted to to the conservation of the
architectural heritage of palestine and
premise thanh an amazing observation it
seems to me that something like I
noticed it was 50 buildings in fifty
thousand more to go there's something
about the number five here because
there's an argument made that that fifty
percent of the heritage is in fifty of
the villages of what one took care of
those 50 villages you would actually be
taking care of the heritage not just of
individual villages but of the
collective of the of the nation or that
which was and will be a nation so then
the sort of 50 villages project but
again I would say why it's a real honor
to the school that you are here you are
already one of our teachers because the
attitude is quite different than you
would find in other preservation context
when the director of the historic
preservation program here myself went to
the center we were immediately students
we were immediately wanting to learn
more because in indy in this situation
not only is this a remarkable number of
villages being thought about but it's
not just that the building is saved the
people who save the building then
develop a new set of skills NGOs are
typically if I remember rightly kind of
installed in the building for the first
few years so there is a kind of social
care as well and so basically hans are
turned back into homes not simply by
being by being preserved and you will
notice that almost all of the buildings
their houses so there is a da masta city
to the whole operation at its scale and
it's edit and and the creating of homes
the creating of jobs and it's not by
accident that the guy is talking about
his children when when describing his
word anyway for these in a million
reasons it means the fact that i'm going
to walk out after seeing this horrific
and i remember when i started this job
one thing that somebody said to me don't
ever ever introduce somebody and walk
out and this is the first time i ever
did
and I super apologized and I hope you
realize how shamed I feel and you will
after you hear this talk which I am
super jealous that I'm going to miss but
I think this is one of the great figures
in the field of historic preservation
field that we are of course regard is
more important than small things like
peace initiatives and that's evidenced
by the poster which presents the single
most radical proposal imaginable as I
say before the only advantage of that
poster is if this is the proposal
there's such a great room for compromise
and one could as it were scaled down
this procedure and have a major victory
anyway it's you do us great honor and it
is our deep wish that students from
architecture preservation and planning
will be actively collaborating and being
students and we would also like to learn
how to to do it and to do it with this
kind of care once again you touch the
school very deeply already and please
feel please feel at home
well I wish Mark would stay and continue
the lecture she's done a better job than
myself um sorry you're leaving because
you could have done it better than
myself well I am really delighted to be
here in the gs app I asked how to
pronounce the GS a PP and then I was
told gzip is the name well thank you
very much for for all of you being here
and I would like to thank Ben for also
inviting me and this started actually
almost a year ago where you do columbia
university has a center in a man with
soft one must redirect ER and then he
came to Palestine Ramallah we went out
and as he said love from the first sight
and it was and then we have the Dean
come visit us in Palestine he came to
ReWalk and also with chairman Andrew and
I am delighted to know after almost
eight months of Correspondence I am here
to share with you the experience of
Faerie walk and I thank you for coming
here I am delighted that the revolution
in Egypt or the is over at least for the
time being because I wouldn't have had
any chance of having any one of you
sitting and listening about historic
preservation rather than listening to
about Egypt probably some of you are
here because of the map I don't know how
many of you notice the map that of the
poster which included Palestine Jordan
and Israel and I think many people
thought that this lecture is going to be
about how the Palestinians became
Egyptians and liberated the whole area
it's not the case some people are here
because they thought israel occupied all
of the area it's not the case some
people who call for a one-state
solution or a confederation between
Palestine Jordan and Egypt it's not the
case it's just a graphic designer
imagination and I just want to tell you
something about myself because I think
normally I don't like to stand in front
of a person not knowing who they are so
I want to just give a personal touch to
it actually today as I was putting few
notes about this lecture I realized that
there were two curfews in my life that
changed my life the first curfew
happened in nineteen ninety one with the
first Gulf War Sharon put us under 42
days of curfew which meant we couldn't
leave the house and what would you do
when for for 42 days not going to school
not teaching not working I kept thinking
thinking thinking and the idea of robot
came about and that's why rework started
in nineteen ninety one now in 2003 2002
Sharon put us under another gaff you for
42 days this time and as a result I
ended up writing my memoirs and that's
what Mark referred to as a book called
Sharon and my mother-in-law and the book
is about two occupations one is sharone
and the Israeli army which occupied my
town Ramallah and the other occupation
is my mother-in-law's who occupied my
house and drove me crazy so she ended up
with two occupations and believe me I
went to architecture because I am
dyslexic you don't know how difficult I
find it to to spell words you know I
don't know how many of you here are
dyslexic but I think I went to study
architecture so because you know how we
architects we like sort of looking at
maps and photographs and hardly eat and
to my biggest surprise I became a writer
by
pure accident as a result of the success
of Sharon and my mother-in-law and for
since 2005 actually I've been traveling
all over the world talking all to my
mother-in-law so if I bore you today
with my architectural presentation you
would know why because I haven't done it
for quite a bit of time I want to share
with you my experience as an architect
and just anyone more anecdote before I
get serious become an architect I was a
graduate of the American University of
Beirut the department of architecture
and I failed every single structure
course anything that has to do with
mathematics I was terrible with again
with dyslexia because every 42 was 24
and every 64 was a 46 and what have you
so I failed all the structural courses
but in the year 2008 I was called by a
UB to be given a price by the department
of architecture or the School of
Engineering and I was totally surprised
but it has nothing to do with my
architectural achievement it has to do
with Sharon and my mother-in-law again
so as I said ReWalk i will be showing
you a film about throughout but before
we do that I would really like to share
with you the experience of what is
ReWalk and what is the status of the
cultural heritage in Palestine reward
which was started in nineteen ninety one
is an NGO is a non-government
organization who is trying very hard to
protect the cultural heritage in
Palestine and I don't say Palestinian
architecture I say architecture in
Palestine because we are trying to
protect all layers in Palestine meaning
that i partly feel Greek I partly feel
Roman I park if you're Byzantine are
partly filled Christian i partly filled
Muslim I partly filled Jewish I partly
filled Turkish I park and fill all of
those and it is very important to have
this
approach to preservation and not to take
a political stand concern concern
protection or conservation and try to
protect one layer only now as a child i
grew up in damascus and any of you who
have been to Damascus would realize the
impact of those streets on a little girl
going around also al-hamid ee i happen
to be lucky to be living in a beautiful
old house the zebra house my mother came
from Damascus so I grew up in a
courtyard house that mud must have left
some imprints in my mind the atmosphere
for me architecture is really the
atmosphere the ambiance that is created
and when I was studying architecture in
AUB in the 70s it was the modern school
of architecture and I hated it I did not
relate neither to the school to the
scale nor to the modern materials and I
always look for the atmosphere in a
space and I figure out it has to do with
space and it has to do with the scale of
the place and of the event the human
being what are they doing and how
they're relating to the space being
Palestinian I would not hide the fact
that i was also draw traumatized by the
loss of my parents house in jaffa also
traumatized by the fact the palestinians
villages 420 were totally demolished
bulldoze owed by the Israelis between
the year 48 and 52 and that must have
left a little bit a fear inside me that
Palestine will disappear all of those
together Damascus my mother's visiting
Italy when i was 18 i must admit also
had an impact of what equality of space
means and what life in a space or any
city or any town really means and
all of those made me go on a visit to
Palestine in 1981 I grew up in Jordan as
a refugee Palestinian refugee and I had
no I knew nobody in Palestine and I did
not know how Palestine looked like
neither the villages north at the
architecture for that matter and at the
end of the day I went to Palestine to
discover it's like hopefully all of you
would be joining us soon to work on some
of these houses now all of those made me
start to walk in 91 and a reward today
is trying to protect the cultural
heritage but not from a material point
of view not from an architectural point
of view but actually trying to tie the
social aspect the economic aspect with
the architectural aspect and we have
created two programs that i will tell
you more about once called job creation
through conservation we have realized
that people have to benefit from their
houses it's not enough to for me to go
and talk about the history of the place
or the beauty of the place if people
don't benefit and I mean benefit either
get a job or get a house or get a a
kindergarten they have to benefit from
those spaces for them to relate to in
Palestine it is very difficult to
protect cultural heritage or historic
buildings for the reasons that we all
share not only in Palestine but also in
America and in north Europe and in India
everywhere in Palestine we have many
challenges that I would share with you
but I would like to show you a 12-minute
film to tell you more about reward
before I move on into the issues of
conservation
you
welcome to the walk the walk was
established in 1991 with the purpose of
protecting cultural heritage in
Palestine we're based in Ramallah but
our work covers the West Bank with a
special emphasis on rural areas this
small presentation will walk you through
our goals or programs and our future
plans our main philosophy is that
protection of cultural heritage for the
sake of protection is neither feasible
not sustainable our objective is to
reestablish the relationship between
heritage and social economic and
cultural activities to make people see
and feel the potentials of investing in
heritage in Palestine heritage can and
should be a main component of a better
future a future that respects celebrates
and built from the past our programs are
multidisciplinary we work along
different but parallel paths our work
started with the biggest project yet the
national registry of all historic
buildings in the west bank gaza and east
jerusalem hundreds of students worked
with us to register the 50,000 320
buildings and 422 sites in palestine
over a period of 10 years the gathered
information can be seen in a
three-volume publication or online anh
duoc register dot org another killer in
the box work is the single building
rehabilitation project this has resulted
so far in more than 100 renovated public
buildings and has managed to show the
100 or so communities the such buildings
can become alive again hosting all kinds
of services and activities
renovated buildings have become
attraction points for local community
members and visitors alike many cultural
activities such as the PAL fest and the
sounding Jerusalem festival has used
these goodies as venules bringing new
cultural experiences too many remote
locations and contributing to a new
mental image of Palestine this has also
contributed to putting many villages and
towns such as Rascar carbon-12 an and
Lara here on the map of alternative
tourism creating potential economic
gains to those places in addition to
gaining a venue for activities and
services spanning around five million
u.s. dollars on restoration has resulted
in the generation of around 170,000
working days for unemployed workers and
has trained hundreds of these workers on
new building skills and had to revive
traditional crafts that were almost lost
working on single buildings made us
realize that we need to intervene on a
larger scale the scale of historic
centers as a whole this means the
preventive conservation of entire blocks
of buildings and public spaces the
rehabilitation of Street infrastructure
the planting of trees the development of
protection plans and strategic documents
with the community from experience each
site has its own problems and potentials
some historic centers can be developed
for tourism while others are needed by
the community for houses but in all
cases these centers can be the hops for
social cultural and economic activities
and this is what we want to see of
course this work is not possible without
the real and direct involvement of the
community our program started different
sector and operate on both the national
and local levels 100,000 school children
participated in our annual drawing
competition 50 teachers participated in
our 2009 training for extracurricular
activities every year we train more than
10 architects a few days on conservation
techniques and last year alone we
planted around 500 trees and historic
centers in 2005 we started the rock
Biennale with three editions so far the
Biennale has become a biannual
opportunity for interaction it provides
a venue for exchange between
international experts practitioners and
interested individuals with a local
community in the different locations of
our work over the years we have
published 11 books on Palestinian
cultural heritage
OMG btwin Julia I'm senior Jenna who
Rosco and eNOS those are the names of
the 50 historic centers we have
prioritized for our work in becoming 10
years from the past 20 years of
experience as you have seen we have been
racing to protect our heritage racing to
put this heritage on the national map
and striving to connect this work to our
national priorities the idea of the 50
came from the fact that these 50 centers
comprise fifty percent of our
architectural heritage a brutal
Palestine the idea of this project is
actually quite simple we have 50 almost
abandoned historic centers made up from
20,000 historic buildings and at home to
the poorest segments of the community at
a time when we as Palestinians need
housing need services need spaces for
social and cultural interactions and are
in a very dire economic need those
20,000 buildings and surrounding spaces
can solve many of the problems we suffer
from bari generating these centers we
can provide at least 10,000 housing
units create tens of thousands of
working days rehabilitate spaces that
are environmentally and child-friendly
provide spaces for economic activity and
create an alternative tourism map of
Palestine a map that celebrates people
and their way of life this project is
about the best use of resources and the
safeguarding of our environment why
build new residential quarters and
facilities when at no cost to the
environment one can use already existing
spaces built in a very socially friendly
manner why build playgrounds at the far
edge of town when one can save
transportation cause I create
playgrounds and spaces that are safe for
children while if such areas abandoned
attracting criminal activities while at
minimal cost we can make them incubators
for socio-economic and cultural
development heritage and Palestine is
not only ours is the heritage of the
entire humanity but we are its keepers
it's not and should not be a static
piece in a museum
it can be a lever that lifts us into the
future we truly believe in the
potentials of this heritage and we want
you to be on our side
okay before I open I I want to speak for
10 minutes just to give you to focus on
three programs that we have done under
water and then I would like to just open
the floor and have an open discussion I
want to tell you about three things one
what we call the happy marriage program
it's difficult to believe that marriage
could be happy but we we tried and I
think we have been successful and then
the international campaign for the
revitalization of the 50 villages and
relax be an ally these are the three
things that I would like to share with
you now the first one as we try to
illustrate in the film here what at the
very beginning we really when we started
we didn't know what to do what cultural
heritage and Palestine was and the best
way to start we thought is to is to get
to know what we have so we started what
we call the national register of
historic buildings hundreds of students
every single student of architecture or
professor or person in history or
archaeology in the five universities of
Palestine went out to collect
information on the 50 villages we ended
up having what we call a listing or an
inventory that you could see online
unfortunately it's only in Arabic I
think with a with a summary in English
but basically we know what we have now
and as a result of understanding what we
have we looked into the 50 villages
50,000 buildings and we found out that
instead of working on 420 villages only
if we concentrate on 50 of them we will
preserve fifty percent of our historic
buildings in other words 50 of these
sites have fifty percent and that's why
we started the 50 the international
campaign to protect these 15 sites now
the happy marriage star
in 2000 in the year 2000 when again
Sharon seem to play a very important
role in my life unfortunately in the
year 2000 Sharon the Prime Minister of
Israel the wake up woke up one day and
decided he doesn't want to have any
workers to work in Israel it means that
hundred fifty thousand palestinians woke
up one day and did not have a job which
means almost a million Palestinian woke
up one day without an income which is
one-third of the population and at that
point we just felt in the work that we
had to her we have to have a role in the
alleviation of employment or
unemployment and we started this project
called job creation basically we came up
with the following idea now many of the
buildings in Palestine in the villages
ReWalk only work in the rural areas the
majority of buildings in the historic
centers are empty so if an owner is
willing to give the use of that building
for ten years we will be willing to
raise the funds to renovate his or her
building meanwhile in these ten years an
NGO from the same community which as you
can see here it's either music children
music mostly we encourage cultural
activities can use this building for
free for the coming 10 or 15 years the
NGO in a village and the owner of the
house will come out with an agreement
that the owner would allow them to use
it for free meanwhile ReWalk would raise
the funds and do the conservation so the
owner is happy and the NGO is happy
because they are using it for free now
the contractors that work with us we
have to have training we do run training
courses for architects and workers and
contractors so we are trying to make
them gain a skill now the contractors it
open tender so we put it in the
newspaper and people apply now who gets
the job among the contractors we have a
point or system in which hiring people
from the community is one major point of
winning that bit it means you cannot
bring workers from Jerusalem Bethlehem
Ramallah or any of those cities and pick
them to this little village you have to
hire people from the village and if they
don't have the skill we can train them
and only in rare cases we will allow
workers from other village to come in or
from other areas we don't always succeed
but we try so the community really start
seeing that this project is an income
for them the community starts feeling
that there is a music center as you saw
in this old historic center the owner is
happy and we started looking at the
people rather than at this tone and this
is very important the minute we started
realizing that really conservation is
about improving the social conditions of
people who are living in that area
because we architects I took as an
architect we have a problem at least
when I studied it was more about the
material proportions and what have you
and we forget about the people who are
using that space now we shifted our work
from the happy marriage we still do
single buildings then we realize that
it's not enough the single building has
been successful because it showed the
people the potential and uses of their
buildings so you could make an old
building into a modern building with the
heating with lighting with good services
because that's why people left their
historic buildings we started working on
the village as a whole and that's why we
have the rehabilitation project and
that's the beginning of the 50 villages
and now we are working on five villages
and shortly what we do is we do a social
and economic study of that village our
aim is to make the services and the
clipping conditions in the old town
equal if not better than the rest of it
down because as it stands today the
historic centers are really bad badly
served only the pool the all the elderly
lives there there is hardly schools
there is hardly any services for the
community so if we come in and try to do
infrastructure just to give you an
example we worked on beers 8 which is
the town in old city next to the
University we have done infrastructural
work our partners are the community our
partners are the NGOs in the community
place and our partners are the
architects and any other person who can
the workers who can help or do the work
themselves now we have started working
on rehabilitation what we do I am
getting technical but I want to do that
for those of you who are interested in
the issues of conservation we do social
and economic studies we want to really
understand the situation who lives there
what they were what is it that they work
where do they work what is the level of
education what are their problems how do
they want their town to look like why is
it that they're leaving it what would
make them stay in it second we try to
serve those who already there before we
start thinking we want people to come
back we want to make sure that people
who live there don't leave it so we do a
program to serve the people who are
already living there by giving them an
upgrading of their houses and it's only
a ten-thousand-dollar a piece a house
and this is kind of you know instead of
going and spending seventy thousand
dollar for a new apartment you give ten
to fifteen thousand for an old house and
then you change the bathroom the
lighting and basically the kitchen and
people would become happy in it so to
rehabilitate means that we have to
attract people to make people stay but
also attract them to come into these
areas and we don't have a magic solution
as you all know each town
we expect successes for example we took
beers 8 which is close to the University
because we thought it was a success
story and we took one of the biggest and
the most remote villages next to Hebron
at bahria which is the biggest village
which is a town now because we thought
we will have a success story and the
more difficult story the success what
was the one next to Hebron the remote
area where we did not think we will
succeed why because people appreciated
somebody coming and asking about them
why because those who know politics of
Palestine they are Hebron eyes I don't
know what is the equal of Hebrew nights
in America it's a sale it's a local joke
about an internal joke about Hebrew
nights being very stubborn very backward
but in reality they are very
interpreters the pub you know they just
took pride in their town and we had
planners sitting down and marking things
in red as school and yellow as clinic
and what have you we go back there all
being used but in Reverse colors doesn't
matter you know so at the end of the day
really I just want to tell you that we
have just started this 5 the
International Campaign of revitalizing
these villages of course it's not as
easy as I am trying to make it sound as
you all know and I would really really
hope that one day we will have a program
with you in Colombia in the Department
of Architecture planning and
preservation here to look together at
one or some of these towns and i am
going to be here so we'll probably will
have more and more informal meetings to
sort of
come to tell you no come to develop
something I will stop here because I am
ha karate as they say in Arabic if you
give me a microphone I never give it
back but this time i will try to stop
for five minutes and if you don't ask
questions i will just continue talking
yes
my name is abdominal I have two
questions these buildings that are being
restored are they being designed by
someone and by if so by who or are they
being restored to a previous state that
they were before and if they are where
are you getting the information from and
then my second question is can you speak
a little bit about the difficulty of
doing all this work under the constant
threat of all of it being destroyed in
one day or in any given moment right you
know the easier one actually weary walk
as an institution we are 15 15 to 20 of
us the majority are architects and
archaeologists we have two missions one
is to raise the funds as I mentioned
before and second is to do the
conservation to supervise the
conservation and till they do the
architectural work and prepare the
tender documents and work as as
conservation architects so far we have
been doing things in-house but soon i
think we it looks like we will be have a
handing it out to some of the offices
architectural offices because of the
scale of the work is becoming a little
bit too much and also to involve others
so it is reworked so far that has been
doing the architectural design and
supervising we do have architects who go
to a chrome and do some courses here and
there and or study conservation so we
are quite equipped to do this kind of
work now as for the use did you ask for
a solid io the second part of your
question was about what are they useful
or yes no this is the second but I
thought the first question had amount
that crap
yes that's what I meant well okay the
information is sometimes we oral history
is quite strong and Palestine so we do
ask people about what they know about
this building we started we try to look
for photos or written information we
don't always succeed and i must say that
sometimes at the beginning of our
conservation we were not a very sincere
in doing the research you know
architects are very keen on starting the
work without doing much research and our
co-director who was an archaeologist
always complain that we never did enough
research on now you have to remember
that mum not all of this building our
monuments in the sense that we have to
keep them in the shape and form that
they first exist we do have a challenge
of having people use their buildings and
we don't use them we don't treat them in
a very sacred way except for those few
that we mark we do what we call
classification one of the research that
we do architectural study of that fabric
is to decide the intervention we do
divide them into a B and C and then we
put regulations to each one of them but
I would say the majority of them because
they are housing we try as much as
possible not to be too conservative
about not touching your own building
still because people don't want to use
them still so it really depends on the
on the value of that building or it's a
statement of MF of importance and now as
to demolitions well we are living in in
political conflict and I can tell you
the following that one of the
difficulties we have I don't know I mean
demolition of housing I hope of whole
villages I hope we never see again it
happened in 48 and I
that in the history of Palestine we
don't see it again but we have another
kind of demolition which is the
development which is happening from the
Palestinians ourselves I mean like
modern development and every time there
is a boom in Palestine we conservation
architects we suffer a great deal now
the occupation influences us in the
following way I don't know how many of
you realize that if we talk about the
West Bank forget Gaza for the time being
in the West Bank the Palestinian
Authority has control over only twelve
percent of Palestinian land these are
areas that are defined as areas a B and
C now area amb are the villages and
towns that Palestinians live on built-up
areas and this a and B are only twelve
percent of the West Bank the rest
eighty-eight percent see area which is
still under Israeli occupation and
jurisdiction and these are where the
settlements are being built how does
that influence the conservation it means
all our historic centers or or historic
cities are sitting on this twelve
percent or ten percent now if I give you
a case of Ramallah for example
Oh from Allah literally ninety percent
of the Ramallah land is sea area and a
area is only that little paper now the
whole population and keeping in mind
that 40 years under Israeli occupation
we were not allowed to build like East
Jerusalem today so since 93 or 94 95
when we got our National Authority
Palestinian National Authority we were
allowed by our Authority and by the
israel is to build on that list little
paper so you have people making up for
the 40 years of math building in
addition to land speculation if you want
to buy a land in Ramallah today in that
piece of paper you will have to add to
build the house you will have to pay at
least at least 300,000 dollars in a nice
area half a million dollar while if you
buy one dunam which is a thousand square
meter on that table it will be ten
thousand dollars so the historic centers
that we are trying to protect are in the
center of this paper so you can imagine
the kind of pressure we have from the
people from the private sector from the
politicians from our government people
accusing us every single day that we are
empty development now lucky enough that
these historic centers really are only
half percent or one percent of that
piece of paper so we always argue do
your development on the 99 percent of
the land do your great architecture on
the 99th and let us just protect this
one percent of that piece of paper so
these are the difficulties that
indirectly or directly we have from the
Israelis if we ever get three ninety
percent we're not talking about Jaffa
heffa or getting back historic Palestine
we are talking only getting jurisdiction
over our West Bank then there will be a
till bit of a release on the historic
centers but these are one of the major
problems we have another problem we have
is the lows we still have British laws
we were ruled in Palestine after the
first world war became would became
british mandate in 19 22 or 23 until 47
and the laws are still there the British
were only interested in archaeological
sites they were not really interested in
Ottoman buildings because most of the
houses we have our during the Ottoman
period 300 400 500 years old so the law
is that we have in Palestine now after
having our Palestinian National
Authority for the last what 16 years we
still have the same rule so reward is
working as the conscious of people we
don't have any laws that protect these
historic buildings somebody wants to
come up tomorrow and demolish their
house we cannot stop them so we're
working in directly with the
municipalities to come up with bylaws
and zoning regulations in which we can
protect these historic buildings
the West Bank and also could you talk a
little bit about Sonny can what was the
first one first one is what is the title
environment like and can people perfect
their ownership pretty easily and move
old abandoned buildings and then the
second question is are there operated
the opportunities like in Gaza because
you really been focusing on the West
Bank yeah well we have actually we were
working in Gaza and when we did our
national register it was Gaza was part
of it but since i would say 96 up till
now of course since 2006 we haven't been
nobody has been able to enter Gaza but
even before that it is almost impossible
for a Palestinian like myself to reach
to Gaza it's impossible for me to reach
Jerusalem it's impossible for me to
reach Israel so I mean you touched on
another issue that I had forgotten to to
mention actually it's very difficult
sometimes to move about in in the West
Bank because in a place which is I
always tell the Italians as the size of
Elba but here it doesn't mean much there
I love Elba Palestine is really very
very tiny and the West Bank has almost
550 checkpoints so it's difficult to
move to move about and that's why
unfortunately I don't mention Gaza
because we have stopped working in Gaza
because we cannot reach Gaza as for
ownership and title of the land and and
houses we have to situation if we are
talking about houses and ownership
within the city it's a very clear
private ownership that has been
registered and people know exactly the
title of their of their houses there is
a problem with land in general
especially in the sea areas because
again during we can always say the
problem is either from the British or
the Israelis it's very easy for the
Palestinians we are not responsible to
any of our the mistakes
but there is something called did not
land registration that happened in the
40s in which the British were trying to
register each person's land and we call
it test VA and this did not happen and
now people know exactly their lands and
they do have proofs but for the Israel
is it's a completely it's a it's a very
complex issue but when it comes to
historic centers we don't have any of
those problems of course we have a
problem of divided ownership because the
house a little house that you saw here
could be owned by 70 people five of them
are in beers it and the 65 are in
California or in Chile or in South so we
do have a problem with ownership but
that's double effect on the one hand
it's good because it means that people
can easily donate their buildings or do
something public that's why it's very
easy for someone to agree to give us
their building or the community to use
it on the other hand it makes our life
difficult sometimes that the ownership
is quite divided and not easy to solve
but it has its implication on our work
planning that's more at the city scale
or is it mostly sort of from building to
building I mean you mentioned zoning but
you also do interventions in the urban
fabric in general or infrastructure on
those but yes as I said we started with
single buildings then then we moved into
the revitalization of a whole town and
what we do y ou will these are the
following steps that we do first we do
as I mentioned before a study we have to
understand the situation there so we do
have social economic architectural
environmental and all the studies that
you can think of that we need to
understand and collect the information
we do have the also the architectural
National Register that I mentioned now
next we do the infrastructure it's very
important for us we find out that
improving the infrastructure in those
villages will make people all the
community feels much better about itself
so infrastructure is one of the things
that we start with so we do all the
electrical mechanical all the electrical
and telephone and what have you lines
come down and also we improve the street
furniture as you saw in some of these
now then we do two three things at the
same time one is what we call a catalyst
buildings instead of renovating because
renovating every single building really
costs a lot of money the average of one
hundred thousand dollars for each one of
those buildings so we don't have this
kind of money so what we do we do what
we call catalyst or Nord projects in the
different neighborhood so we will have
one two three buildings one could be a
cultural center one is for the
municipality and one for the University
for example we think very strong what
will bring people in if we make it a
post office if we make it a clinic so
many times bringing people into the
neighborhood is very important but these
are mostly decided as I
it's not enough for me to decide things
have to happen on the community level so
it is mostly the community that come up
with the ideas and there are the ones
who read friend the building and they're
the ones who take but we have catalyst
building and the money we bring we also
spend on something called preventive
conservation preventive conservation is
is like making the whole town looks
better by cleaning it by doing cleaning
the facade of the buildings by emergency
fund that if a building is about to fall
will sort of make the buildings or the
whole historic Center live for another
50 years so if we cannot do it now it's
there for the coming years for us to
work on so this is what we call
preventive conservation then we work as
I mentioned before on housing we start
with the people who live there we do
have a social we try as much as possible
if it's a small community we serve the
whole community which means we give
10,000 we specify the work we sit with
them and see what is it they want they
normally say kitchen they normally say
water who bails normally say a door or a
a window and we try to serve the
community that is there so they can stay
but also we look into the possibility of
new uses for their buildings like in the
case of visit for example one person
came and renovated the building and made
it a restaurant there now our philosophy
really is to try as much as possible to
have the community use the building and
muck to have it become like a museum or
you know just people coming from outside
or or depending on tourism from outside
that part that we have much so yes to
answer your question is yes we do work
on the scale of the whole village we
look into environmental issues into
green you know
environmental and planting sewage
systems water systems all the
environmental issues that were there in
the past and people stopped using and we
look forward to new thinking I hope that
you know we can sit down and discuss
other possibilities of how to go about
things but we try to work on the 11 and
as I told you the municipality is our
main partner in this we work with the
municipality and often we help the
municipalities to start a unit of
conservation and we hire an architect or
two and it is paid part of the project
for the coming two three four years so
it is really owned one of the most
difficult part of our work is to make
people feel or for people to really own
the project and not for us just to say
it and it is a challenge yes
what's the time frame that you're
looking at right well when we did our
narrower National Register we considered
50 years and the reason for 50 years in
the case of Palestine of course we
looked into different countries and
different countries had 50 years or
hundred years depending or 70 years in
our case at that time when we started 50
years was the end of this use of the
crosswauld or the end of agrarian
depending on agriculture as a production
mode in Palestine of course it started
much earlier in the 20s and 30s but it
reflected itself in the architecture
sometime in the mid 40s and now as we
all know as conservation architects that
the National Register should be updated
in other words every ten you know every
ten years then it becomes the year 50
then 60 then 70 but we haven't done that
because that's an army of work and the
budget you know that that research we we
did it took us 13 years and it cost us 1
million dollar to do that National
Register and we haven't been able to
update and continue the work for it so
50 years is but as I told you it is in
our mind in our practice but we don't
have a law that says that yes please
yeah go ahead
I don't know if you would agree with me
that depending on the different
traditions the different cultures the
concepts such as a conservation
restoration renovation have slightly
different meanings also and actually
besides this one's conservation
renovation restoration I'd like to for a
moment talk about the another one which
is like to call Reese erection and
especially that we are in the holy land
here well actually I were going to point
more at the at the Byzantine context or
the Byzantine tradition which you
mentioned that you are affected partly
by it too and I'm thinking about the the
enormous amount of religious buildings
that Stalin destroyed in the 30s and 40s
byzantine temples and these ones are
being renovated sorry not renovated they
are being rebuilt from scratch that's
what i like to call Reese erected and it
seems that in the in the best Byzantine
tradition they don't have any prominent
doing this in other words it doesn't
affect the weather it could be a party
tour at Disneyland for its you know it's
real it's authentic even though it's
been built yesterday and under that
light and this Byzantine spirit i would
like to ask you how would you feel about
the possibility of resurrecting or
building back from scratch the
palestinian villages that were destroyed
in the 40s while we're trying to very
hard to keep the ones that we have
before resurrection I mean we do have a
challenge of keeping before hundred that
remained and I would say that is a
a priority a practical priority but for
you know for discussion I want to tell
you the following that a lot of this
discussion really happens in our in
ReWalk as architects because we do have
different schools of toads as you
probably we didn't have enough chance to
look at the different buildings that we
have renovated but we do have people
think differently I am perhaps one of
the more conservative ones in
conservation I always tell them that the
building looked much better before we
did it which is true most of the time we
go into a building and I love it and
after we have renovated I said oh my god
what we have done to the building of
course we have to be practical and I
think as I mentioned we are not the
conservation group even though some of
us in the sense that the building is
more important than the human being we
are in a probably situation in which we
are willing to compromise only you know
the history of the building if you want
but also who said you know we have one
architects amongst us who believes that
the building is a living thing and we
should allow it to build and it's only a
dream to keep a building as is and he's
right I mean we the world changes and we
always have the static feeling as if you
know it was good in the past and it's
not good anymore so part of our work is
really allowing for modification
allowing for additions and the sort of
controlling how additions go or how
changes go again you know to the your
question about the destroyed villages
there has been one attempt actually with
a group of israeli-palestinian
international architects that are trying
to protect lift there may be some of you
are on this mission
I must say it's not easy with the with
the Israelis nothing is easy with the
Israelis but I think that it is
important like I don't know how many of
you are aware of the district 6 Museum
in South Africa you know this is an area
that has been destroyed by apartheid
government and the people now in cape
town came back and they had a group
called district 6 it was called the
success and it was demolished because it
was a mixed population there and the
white regime just demolished it and send
people away and there is a museum now
called district 6 where people from all
over kept their history and the object
the artifacts they brought it and they
have a map when you go into the district
6 museum you have a map drawn of the
houses and people have come even before
you know the clerk before the regime
fell they have collected the material
and now they are rebuilding it but so
maybe the political circumstances you
know after seeing Egypt falling mubarak
falling everything is possible in that
area and that's why I say it is the
Middle East and you never expect what
will happen so thank you it's very
interesting we have a person there that
has been trying yes
thank you side thank you very much you
gave me an new hope and a new
appreciation for Sharon I I'm curious
how how the name came about about the
ReWalk if you can just tell me how how
what it means and and I am embarrassed
to say I haven't heard of your
organization yeah oh I want to follow up
with the other question about the
villages that we lost and it has there
been any energy or effort to even
virtually create some of those villages
and have you branched out to deal with
the what what many talk about the
picturesque landscape of those villages
that I know is probably hard to recreate
ReWalk actually you know reward in
Arabic means the gallery you know like
na it's the group of arches which is
like a cloistered in the building that
is arawak Arawak also is in a very
typical architectural element in
Palestine in village houses you walk
into the courtyard and part of that
courtyard has a crawl across vault which
is covered but open which is 81 or it's
called drew walk but and also there was
a school of rock hewn it was a
philosophical school that the teacher
like Aristotle would be walking in the
gallery and this group were called ruin
after him like the gallerist but to tell
you the truth when we started ReWalk i
decided to call it karma
I don't know how many of you know what
more Armas is mo Karma's is what is it
in English satellites cutter satellite
what is it called Stella's yes what is
it in English stalactites stalactites
you know this is like an intellectual
professor of architecture at visit
University starting an organization and
it calls its organization Cardinals and
in Arabic is like in English I can
hardly pronounce the word so we went out
and there is actually a grabar the you
know the art historian or the of Islamic
art in Harvard has a magazine called
harmless and that's why I thought you
know I wanted to be the intellectual
side call it Karnas when we started
working in the street and telling the
peasants were the normal people
Buchanan's what bernos you know byrne
nose is like Bureau at the bathroom rope
that you were you know it's like burners
people nobody had an idea how to what it
was all about and what it event and they
distorted at the end of the day we said
come on side just pick up a word that
everybody knows and reworked is the word
that everybody knows because everybody
if you go to a village they will say
come on come come and see let me show
you our ReWalk so that's how the name
came about now about the destroyed
villages I am happy to tell you in a
sense that there has been very intensive
work done on preserving the history the
social history and the description of
that of the 42 villages there is a book
called all that remains in english and
in arabic it's called kyle an answer so
we do not forget this book is published
by professor is edited published how do
you buy professor well if a lady
and it is a publication of the Institute
of Palestine studies and there has been
a documentation like our National
Register people went researchers went to
Jordan Palestine Syria Lebanon wherever
the Palestinian refugees existed went
around and asked them and to describe
the village and to draw a map about the
village so there is an interesting
documentation but i wouldn't say an
architectural documentation and there is
our city what's his first name salman
abu city also has done work on the
palestinian villages the names and it's
very intriguing because there is also a
very interesting book written by an
Israeli geographers by member nasty and
it's called the Palestinian sacred
landscape and it's one of the
interesting resources because it comes
from the other side and he was a boy or
he was ten years old when he used to go
around with his dad his dad was a
geographer and his dad's mission wants
to take the map the British map Arab
names of the villages and just go and
start making up new names that sounds
either you know Hebrew name names and he
talks about the Judy ization of names of
the place and it's quite intriguing
because he says how many times really it
has nothing to do biblical or nothing
historical but they will create names
that will laugh so you know the whole
issue of geography archaeology is quite
a field between the Palestinians and
the Israelis and one of the most
annoying thing is how much that place
changes all the time on you to a point
where you feel a stranger all the time
but that's a completely different topic
i always say time and space and
palestine have a completely different
meaning you never know when you get to a
place and every two years the place
changes on you you don't know where you
are we are continuous cinema paradise
you in that part of the world let's try
to keep it yes it is a little bit
curious about where you get your funding
and where most of your support comes
from right what your relationship is
with the PA if they offer any support at
all and then also I know the water
infrastructure and the West Bank isn't
too great if you could just speak about
the infrastructures and any hurdles that
you have to go over with that too in the
listening as far as funding is concerned
for the longest time our main funder was
Sweden and the reason for that Sweden is
very interested in culture not only in
cultural heritage but also in culture
and in hospitals these are they
specialized their speed so see down
which is not see that the Canadians
idiot Swedish has been our main but also
we have funding from other resources or
almost every other European country like
the Germans
the Dutch the bells
Ford Foundation the Arab fund for
economic development in Kuwait had
become increasingly the second in
funding us after the Swedish UNDP
sometimes we do projects with them we
don't get any funding from the P and a
because the PN or needs the fund
actually we are happy if they don't take
our money so it's the other way around
they hardly have money and that's why I
think this is another issue we don't
have much time to talk about the role of
the NGO Palestine is incredibly stronger
than the government in many areas so
that's something that gives us a lot of
space to to work on now the issue of
water is another difficult issue because
as we know part of the problem with our
conflict with Israel is our rights over
water they they consume ninety percent
of the water and we consume ten percent
of the water of our own wonders so it is
quite a bit of a of a problem and
actually you start feeling it on
everyday level well you don't have water
every day in many of the Palestinian
towns and villages so it is quite a
a problem and that's why I think the
whole issue of having water wells should
come back because traditionally every
single house used to have a water heater
well and if I were the mayor I would
make that obligatory they haven't done
that done that yet the issue of of
sewage is a big problem in Palestine the
reason for that again is whenever you
want to have a treatment plant for a
city like Ramallah or beer together you
need a sewage plant how do you call the
treatment plant and it has to be in the
area and the Israelis will not give us a
permit until unless we agree that this
sat there will be peace between the
settlers that our sewage and the
subtlest sewage will be together that's
their vision of peace with the
Palestinians and you know we hope for
more than that so there has been
problems with really you will be
surprised that for example in a place
like romana the old centers the historic
centers where we work have sewage
treatment I'm in sewage pipes from the
Roman periods but the new modern areas
in Palestine don't have so sewage so
unfortunately up till now we all have
septic tanks and that you know how
terrible it is for the environment and
sipping water and pollution but i am not
an expert on on water and sewage really
in Palestine but I know that there are
quite serious issues yes please
I'm wondering if rioc works at all with
refugee camps in the area and if so
maybe not so much preservation maybe
renovation and if there's a
collaboration with Andrew Wow at all
this simple question the simple answer
is no the short answer is no and the
long answer is yes now the short answer
is no because really the as you all know
the refugees has been created in that
you know as a result of 1948 so these
are areas which we have not yet
considered historic but maybe soon as
the question raised here which years are
historic soon them some of these places
will have to be preserved and have been
have to be registered and considered
really historic as we all know that the
value of a building is not only the
material value but also the social and
political event that could have happened
the only way we work with jela's own
camp is that we have done something I
didn't mention to you we have done a
program which deals with trails we don't
only deal with single buildings or with
villages or historic site we try to make
a trail to connect the landscape with
the villages with your archaeological
site and with and part of that is social
and the jealous own camp which is one of
the camps next to Ramallah is part of
our trained to understand the historic
context and the social context of the
environment so in that respect we have
jealous soon as part of our we are part
of a euromed project and this is
now the dire the new director of rework
actually is an anthropologist and his
main research is on refugee camps and it
has to do with memory and space so
that's why i told you in a short answer
no in a long answer yes so if you are
interested in that you write to the new
director of a walk and he is a
specialist on refugee memory and space
and what he studying basically is how
people when they came back home even
though it was honor why that built the
houses for them how they illuminated
depending on which village which
community they came so they try to
recreate their villages and becomes yes
have you ever come in contact with a
municipality that wasn't really easy to
work with or that didn't want reacts
relax help and in places where there's a
more robust private market like in
Jordan or Lebanon um can this model be
exported where maybe the private market
isn't really interested isn't really
interested in conservation doing the
work in spite the municipalities it's a
good question yes we have actually I can
tell you that the success or failure of
our project normally depends on the
local community whether it being the
municipality all the people in general
who are interested or not interested the
success depends a great deal on the
municipality as I told you the project
that we took because we didn't think we
will be successful the municipality
turned out to be so active that it was a
success story we have a case in a
village were the mayor if it's not his
house or his brother's house or his
uncle's house is not interested so we
have cases actually we won't stop the
project which was a two hundred twenty
thousand dollars with a conservation of
a house a palace because the neighbor
would not cooperate and the municipality
didn't want to do anything about it so
we said goodbye I mean the community was
really we realized we cannot do much if
the community is not interested and
that's why I really think that ninety
percent of the word is drinking tea and
coffees if I have an ulcer that is why
that is my job in Andhra walk it's just
to you have
to connect with the people other work
the work doesn't happen but yes we have
encountered cases where we were
unsuccessful because the mayor was very
I'm just wondering if you have other
allies in your work I know you pair with
municipalities on a local level but it
seems like it's very ambitious work yeah
yeah no I am thankful to you because you
have mentioned what we call our partners
and we are proud of them we are so proud
that I forgot them I forgot to mention
you know our partners first really the
cultural centers you could feel it
perhaps from the two things that we do
connect with cultural centers in
Ramallah but also in the village it is
very important for us to believe bring
life so we have a lot of projects for
example with the music conservatory we
connect with cultural organizations
because those organizations want to have
centers all over the villages so instead
of us going and do any kind of activity
we connect with the music center and it
is the one who choose the building and
it's the one who decide and we have seen
some of their work here so our partners
are the cultural centers our partners
are the municipality our partners are
the students of beers it and depending
universities our partners is what we
call friends of ReWalk which are young
people that you have seen some of them
who are interested to know about
cultural heritage because we do have a
lecture series like now and we have what
we can call relax trip we just take
people for fun you know it doesn't have
to be serious hard work and people just
go to villages we have the Biennale that
I didn't have a chance to talk about
every two years we do have a wax
biennale in which we involve the local
community we don't do our conference in
a hotel or in Ramallah we do our
conferences in the villages and we bring
you know experts from all over the world
not only architects worth artist and as
rapala gist and
name it and they come to these villages
look at it and they all have
contributions and so these are our
partners okay thank you very much
you